so memetic so people understand it it's
just trying to imitate others is that
correct
it's imitating other people but
imitating them at the level of their
desires so the reason you know we use
the word memetic is that imitation is
something that's a bit more visible
something that we're aware of mimesis or
mimetic desire goes under a surface
level limitation to the very imitation
of interior things like what other
people want so we're imitative creatures
we that's how we learn math it's how we
learn language it's how we learn all
kinds of cultural norms
and many people have known that for a
very long time what Rene Gerard
discovered who is The Thinker that
really inspired my book is that we
imitate really profoundly interior
things like what other people want from
a very young age starting with their
parents starting with maybe our siblings
and our friends and that informs a lot
of the decisions that we make in life
from what major we choose in college to
what kind of career we go into and we
usually don't even understand how that
process is playing out inside of us so
the obvious question
in everyone's mind would be where am I
supposed to get my desires from if not
from my social contexts my peers uh
those around me I would say you have to
get them from from somewhere you know
one of the main points in the book is
that we don't generate our desires out
of thin air we don't generate them out
of nothing you know this is called this
is a romantic lie
um that I think we we have in a highly
individualistic culture we're social
creatures and our desires are going to
come from other people real fictional
historical right they don't have to be
people on social media they don't even
have to be the people that we interact
with every day I've been deeply
influenced by you know books that I that
are 500 years old you know in history
and models of Desire that I've taken
have drawn on from a bigger universe so
I think maybe it's time to expand our
universe the same thing with when I was
an entrepreneur all of of my models all
of my influences came from this very
insulated world of Las Vegas startups
and it was only when I sort of admitted
other influences in my life like you
know hey maybe I should kind of look
outside of this little bubble that I'm
in
um that my my world started to open up a
little bit so you know I think we need
to be just be intentional about the
kinds of people that are affecting what
it is that we want because normally we
just take it for granted you know we we
think that everything that we want is
the product of our autonomous selves and
so there is some aspect of having the
humility to realize that we are
influenced but we can choose who we're
going to be influenced by I live in the
middle of Washington DC so I've got a
you know I need to be careful about you
know I can't even go to a bar with my
wife without sometimes being negative
influenced by the quality of the
conversations that I hear in every TV
being you know cable news you know 24
hours a day so I have to look outside of
the world that I'm and even today the
way you structure your book uh what was
about kind of the dissent of where
memetic desires lead you and then you
talk about various techniques and
counter measures uh to examine them more
deeply which I enjoyed and I
did examine my own life a bit I guess it
would be impossible not to now the
entrepreneurial mindset or approach
through uh thick and thin has actually
fueled me for a long time
um and uh my approach to it has been
solve a problem problems like hey like
why aren't there enough entrepreneurs
and I spent six years on that and then
the next was hey uh like why aren't we
responding to Ai and advancing
Technologies uh maybe we should
alleviate poverty and get in front of
this thing before AI comes and displaces
millions of us and then now it's hey our
political system seems deeply broken and
dysfunctional like uh you know let me
work on that so you're you're an
expectant uh parent
um you're going to be a dad for the
first time and that's an awesome time
and journey I did relate that the first
year I was a father was the toughest
year of my adult life where this
entrepreneurial mindset you you have at
least for me it totally failed me
um because you get there and you're like
okay what am I supposed to do like let's
just be can do and uh positive and
optimistic
um and in the context of having a
newborn a lot of it just didn't matter
didn't work a friend of mine said
something to me that stuck with me he
said it's the only time in your life
that just saying okay I'll just work
harder is a total non-answer
and and so it stretched my soul in a
particular direction
um it led me to see uh deficiencies in
myself and my family uh in a way that I
hadn't known but this is a long-winded
way of asking like if people are on a
version of this journey how do they
start to find what you call these other
models of Desire or something that can
be more lasting and sustaining and might
lead to fulfillment growth personal
satisfaction so there's a difference in
the book between thin desires which are
these highly mimetic shifting desires
the things you want today that you're
highly unlikely to want six months or a
year from now and then thick desires and
just to relate this to what you were
describing Andrew because I I've got a
baby on the way and we were talking a
bit before we got started about what
that first year was like to you there's
something about grounding yourself in a
concrete situation or concrete sort of
objective problem not to call a baby a
problem but there are a lot of
challenges right and it's there's
something incarnational about it that
somehow strips away the thin stuff you
know and and I think having some kind of
groundedness
um real problems you know um
are a way to sort of remember what's
important which is another way worse and
then the thin desires will fall away you
well you know I it usually we don't need
to go looking for those things you know
unfortunately yeah yeah you know so you
know my dad has Alzheimer's and you know
that's been an incredibly grounding
thing in my life for the past few years
every time that I'm with him life
becomes very simple you know and like
all of these um you know crazy ideas
that I have some are good some are
probably not so good
um they they sort of
they they recede and I I'm able to focus
on something that's incredibly important
to me I have my our baby's not even born
yet and from what I hear there's really
nothing like the moment the baby is born
but already
I've found some of my thin desires
fading away a bit and I I know my wife
would say the same thing so there is
um I think grounding oneself in
something real and incarnational is is
an important first step and and then
just kind of reflect and there's there's
also an element of history with thick
desires so you know when I've reflected
back on my whole life going back as
early as I can remember like little
league baseball growing up the things I
really cared about
um and then kind of tracing your own
history of desire and like how what
you've wanted have changed over time
like I wanted to be a doctor I literally
applied to med school because I watched
a lot of ER with my mom and I thought
George Clooney was really cool and then
just sort of seeing the way that
different influences have played out in
my life you know Tony Shea being another
one gives me perspective to see like
patterns and I gained some pattern
recognition and I see you know Luke
usually when you're involved in
something that integrates all of these
things it's something that you do for a
very long time you know it's like
sustainable for you when you are
attracted to something and it feels like
this if it feels like a push in the back
rather than a gentle nice tug at the
front of your shirt there's a difference
between the way that those two things
feel kind of like getting caught up in a
Riptide I now know what those things
feel like and part of why I know what
they feel like is because I've went
through this process of looking back at
my life very carefully and seeing what
happened when I pursue certain past
based on you know whether those
influences were kind of strong memetic
influences or whether there was
something a bit more enduring and
peaceful about my involvement in those
things
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you